en cette fin d'été foucault et pauline
ont décidé de se mettre au vert des
vacances à la campagne tous frais payés
ce jeune couple a été sélectionné pour
passer une semaine clef en main dans ce
gîte niché au coeur du morvan
ça nous permet finalement de chercher un
endroit où s'installer en rencontrant
des personnes quoi plutôt que de
chercher comme ça dans l'eau dans le
vague ou juste sur internet sans savoir
où on va atterrir foucault et ébéniste
pauline kinésithérapeute
le couple travaille en région parisienne
mais aujourd'hui cette famille et en
recherche active d'une maison à la
campagne cette semaine dans la nièvre
pourrait les convaincre de s'y installer
on n'a pas les moyens d'habiter paris en
fait enfin avec un atelier et parce
qu'on a envie de vivre un peu plus
lentement et avec plus d'espèces de
notre rythme depuis six jours 80
familles venant de toute la france teste
un changement de vie dans la nièvre
une opération à 100000 euros financés
par le conseil départemental et les
intercommunalités pour la foire booster
l'économie touristique mais surtout
séduire des familles désireuses de
changer de vie un projet victime de son
succès près de 600 candidatures ont été
déposées l'idée c'est effectivement de
pouvoir faire de l'accompagnement
personnalisé de ses 560 familles et des
profils qu'on a pu récupérer pour
pouvoir leur faire découvrir ce
territoire à la fois les élus à la fois
les acteurs économiques à la fois le
monde associatif pour pouvoir les
accompagner à ce changement de vie une
opération qui visiblement porte ses
fruits
sylvain est interne en médecine générale
il a pu mesurer tout le potentiel du
territoire est tombé sous le charme de
son patrimoine
le jeune médecin ne ferme pas la porte
un déménagement dans le département moi
personnellement
voilà je n'avais pas d'à priori ni
positif ni négatif
c'est vrai que oui j'en trouverai
demain salle et potentiellement à la
campagne donc je pense que vraiment la
nièvre a vraiment en vrai charme et du
potentiel donc entre moments de détente
et rendez vous professionnel anne fadela
ont également pu apprécier les charmes
et les atouts de la nièvre et de femmes
travaillent en région parisienne avec le
confinement elles se disent prêtes à
opérer un changement de sa amplifié
l'envi vraiment le confinement où il a
été le le la graine était planté mais je
pense que ça a fait fleurir la graine
quoi le gie penser évidemment puisque je
suis là pour visiter des maisons
et puis faire l'équipe faire
l'acquisition d'une petite maison d'une
petite maison pas loin de paris essayez
la nièvre est une opération destinée à
durer dans le temps
le département envisage de renouveler
l'expérience sous une autre forme
aux vacances de la toussaint et de noël